big day big announcement new company
alert much like Vayner Sports Vayner
watt has been announced this is
action Studio that will put out shows on
the screen
most of all I'm excited because it
really speaks to the thing that I want
to make the video about that it's about
relationships I've known Eric for over a
decade you know unlike when you're a kid
and you're kind of guessing who you're
doing business with and I've been in
Intimate business with Higgins for well
over a decade but I've had an actual
relationship with watt when he was at
CAA we've always kept in touch I know
who he is one of the things that a lot
of people should be doing more is
actually doing business with friends or
people they respect people they actually
know so that's what this video is about
hoping that it inspires somebody to
actually start a business with somebody
they actually know you know what you're
getting into and I know people are
scared to do business with friends but
when you really really really are
transparent with yourself then you have
the ability to be transparent with
others and produce meaningful businesses
and TV shows